wusstet ihr dass man in deutschland
erdnüsse anbauen kann das behauptet
zumindest das internet ich möchte dieses
jahr ausprobieren ob das wirklich
funktioniert ich habe meine ersten
ergebnisse gesät die werden dann in
meinen garten gepflanzt und dann werde
ich euch berichten wie das ganze
funktioniert das so sind übrigens super
faszinierende pflanzen die nüsse wachsen
nämlich gar nicht von anfang an unten in
der erde sondern die pflanze bildet ganz
normal überirdisch blüten aus dann
bilden sich daran die kleinen nüsse wenn
die blüten verblüht sind und je größer
die nüsse in diesen bösen werden desto
mehr denken sie sich dem erdboden
entgegen dann bohrt die pflanze die ihr
müsse in den boden und so gelangen sie
erst dahin dass es sozusagen sonst würde
sie ihre eigenen kinder selber pflanzen
total cool und fasziniert ich bin super
gespannt wie das dann in echt aussehen
wird in unserem garten lockt wieder das
war wirklich beobachten werden ich bin
auf jeden fall ja jetzt schon vorher und
klammert wir dieses experiment sagt mir
schon mal erdnüsse angebaut haben oder
ob ihr lust habt dieses experiment
dieses jahr mit mir zu machen und auch
ein paar das in euren garten pflanzen
werdet schreibt mir gerne mal in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet ich bin
auf jeden fall sehr gespannt ich habe
mir saatgut von zwei verschiedenen
herstellern bestellt bei dem ein mann
leider nur noch krümel drin da ist
irgendwas beim transport schief gegangen
also probieren wir jetzt mal die aus sie
sagen dass ich jetzt 24 stunden
einweichen bevor ich sehe die erde sehr
mag ich viele hier drin auch eine kapuze
oder 2
seit die samen hier die last sich jetzt
über nacht einweichen in einem glas mit
wasser damit ihr schon mal vorkommen
können dass es oft ganz gut hat trägt
damit mehr samen anwachsen ich gerne
übrigens nach den aussagen von maria tun
das ist der demeter aussaat kalender und
da sind alle tage ich habe das schon
ziemlich ruiniert jedes heft beim
auszählen
da sind alle tage aufgeteilt in frucht
wurzel blüte oder platt tage
fruchtgemüse wäre sowas wie tomate
wurzelgemüse natürlich möhren und sogar
und da versuche ich immer an den fünf
tagen ist fruchtgemüse zu serien an den
wurzel tagen das wurzelgemüse di maria
tun hat da ganz viele experimente
gemacht mit den aussagen und
festgestellt dass es wirklich einen
großen unterschied macht ob man das
gemüse an den richtigen takt oder nicht
ob man jetzt dran glaubt oder nicht es
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen typsache ich
glaube fest daran und habe damit sehr
gute erfahrungen gemacht den links zu
denen außer tagen dazu diesem haushalt
können da kann ich euch gerne nochmal
hier unter dem video in die video
beschreibung packen so die samen sind
gut vor gequollen ich packe jetzt
jeweils zwei samenkörner jedes dieser
töpfchen
ich möchte am ende gerne vier pflanzen
haben nur so kann ich sicher gehen dass
dann auch in jedem töpfchen einsame
aufgeht und wir haben ende vier kräftige
pflanzen haben falls in einem töpfchen
zwei pflanzen aufgehen entscheide ich
mich einfach für die kräftigere pflanze
und reißt die anderen raus aber es ist
aber so haben wir dann am ende vier
kräftige pflanzen die wir in den garten
pflanzen könnten
[Musik]
wir brauchen eine kein temperatur von
mindestens 25 grad im wegen des sehr
warm zu kleinen deswegen stelle ich
meine auf die heizung das ist allerdings
keine heizung die den ganzen tag volle
pulle aufgedreht ist ich werde meistens
maximal auf drei er mit ein bisschen
unter so dass die adresse schon schön
warm aber nicht zu beraten werden und
erdnuss pflänzchen sind mittlerweile
aufgegangen ich habe jetzt auch in so
größere töpfchen hier um gepflanzt weil
die doch sehr schnell sehr wenig clubs
hatten in den kleinen töpfchen ich bin
ganz erstaunt wie schnell die wachsen
die sehen oft wunderschön aus und
natürlich habe ich es nicht übers herz
gebracht die einzelnen schwächeren
airbus plätzchen auszureißen deswegen
haben wir jetzt doch ein paar mehr
pflänzchen jedes euch auch immer so ich
bin immer sofort als herzlichkeit für so
kleine pflanzen ich kann die bahn
eigentlich fressen
es ist mitten in der nacht ich bin
gerade noch mal aufgewacht und ins bad
gegangen wo meine jungpflanzen
geradestehen
und da habe ich was ganz süßes
beobachtet die erdnüsse die klappen
nämlich wenn es dunkel ist die blätter
zusammen jetzt ob sie die augen zu
machen würden
irgendwie schön eklig und von meinem
gefühl her würde ich die ergebnisse erst
mitte mai raus pflanzen wenn keine
früchte mehr drohen kann sagen dass es
denen dann in die körbchen auch schon
wieder zu eng wird und ich sie nochmal
umtopfen muss wir werden sehen wenn ihr
andere erfahrungen gemacht habt und die
schon früher ausgepflanzt habe dann lass
mich das gerne mal unten in den
kommentaren wissen ich werde euch auf
jeden fall berichten wie es mit dem
erdnüssen weitergeht hier drüben findet
ihr noch ein anderes spannendes video
und da unten auch ich freue mich wenn
wir uns da gleich wieder sehen bis dann
tschüss